the election recounts have finally
halted and Democrats have reluctantly
Rican seated
but swear to fight another day meanwhile
in Europe bureaucrats trampled the will
of the people and tried to kill brexit
we will analyze undemocratic liberalism
and illiberal democracy then young
people stopped having sex a homeless bum
scams America and Google has an anti
labor labor movement on its hands
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael no leo
[Music]
huzzah the impossible has happened
Democrats have conceded an election in
Florida we didn't think it was possible
it hasn't happened for 15 or 20 or 50
thousand years but Democrats have done
it Andrew Gilliam the Democrat running
for governor has finally rican seated
and bill Nelson the senator Democrat
from Florida has conceded to Rick Scott
we will analyze what it means and why
and how the left not just in the US but
broadly is trying to undermine both
liberalism and democracy but first let's
make a little money honey that's very
important to economic freedom Robin Hood
is an investing app that lets you buy
and sell stocks ETFs options and Kryptos
all commission-free it's simple and
intuitive clear design with data
presented in an easy to digest way learn
more at knowles canto wles robin hood
calm this is a really important because
a lot of services that will help you
invest they cost money there are some
commission fees other brokerages can
charge up to 10 bucks for every trade
Robin Hood doesn't charge Commission at
all trade the stocks and keep all of
your profits that's why it's so so good
it's really easy to use easy to
understand shorts market data you can
place a trade in just four taps on your
smart phone I won't do anything that
requires more than five taps that just
have tires and we have too much I'm too
millennial for that Robin Hood is also
lets you view stock collections like the
100 most popular sectors like
entertainment social media curated
categories and analyst ratings of buy
hold sell for every single stock you
learn it by doing you'll learn how to
invest as you build your portfolio you
can discover new stocks and track your
favorite companies with personalized
news feed custom notifications for price
movements you never miss the right
moment to invest right now Robin Hood is
giving listeners a free stock like Apple
Ford or sprint to help build your
portfolio now imagine if you sold up for
Robin Hood if you signed up in the early
1990s and you got a free piece of Apple
stock you'd be retiring right now you'd
be on a beach somewhere sipping a mai
tai
listening to this show SoCo do it you're
getting a free stock NOLs dock Robin
Hood calm Knolls dot Robin Hood dot-com
sign up right now okay the impossible
what a great day what a wonderful
celebration Democrats have conceded
races Ron de santis the Republican has
officially beat
Andrew Gilliam he is now the governor of
Florida or governor-elect of Florida he
won this race by thirty four thousand
votes that's out of eight million votes
cast so he won it by 0.41% Andrew
Gilliam was holding out he was hoping
that all of those fraudulent Democrat
votes that were pouring in we're gonna
bring that number down to 0.25 percent
at which point that would have triggered
under Florida law and manual hand
recount and automatic rather hand
recount so he was really hoping for that
there was rampant corruption going on in
this case there were provisional ballots
being discovered days after the election
Democrat activists were backing up
truckloads full of ballots into election
headquarters it was a total farce
Brenda Snipes was the election
supervisor of Broward County it looks
like she's gonna be forced to resign now
and this is true also in the Senate race
so Andrew Gilliam in in the governor's
race
he finally conceded he tweeted out I
want to congratulate Rhonda Santos on
becoming the next governor of the great
state of Florida my wife RJ or period J
a I didn't have its interest I hope I'm
pronouncing that right and I could not
be prouder of the way we ran this race
we could not be more thankful to my
running mate Chris King and his wife
Kristin okay so he congratulate Sam
that's good
I was had a little trepidation here when
I read this because Andrew Gilliam has
conceded at this race before and then he
unconsidered it because he realized that
he could try to steal the election but
unfortunately it didn't work out for
them so he he goes on he says we are
going to keep fighting we will keep
working and in the end I believe that we
will win I'm so thankful to each and
every one of you so what does that mean
it sounds like the sort of thing when
you lose a race you say we're gonna keep
fighting you're saying I'm gonna I
believe that we will win now that's what
he said after the election because he
kept inventing all of these new votes
that were coming in and in and in but
this is the typical Democrat move it is
the perpetual campaign the campaign is
never over loss doesn't matter loss is
only a temporary setback because the
wheels of history are moving they are
progressing inevitably toward the future
toward utopia
and Bill Buckley when he started the
National Review the conservative
flagship newspaper at that time a
magazine rather said that a conservative
is one who stands a thort history
yelling stop so the left the Democrat
Party they're saying that we're gonna
keep fighting we're gonna win this is
this is barely even a loss we're gonna
win we're gonna barrel through we're
gonna win and the conservative says stop
this is not just true in America it's
true in Britain as well as we're gonna
see the other race in Florida is Rick
Scott beating out Bill Nelson and Bill
Nelson I think has served three terms in
the Senate long-standing Democrat
senator Rick Scott beat him by at last
count ten thousand votes so this was
after a triggered a machine recount it
triggered a manual recount but as many
provisional ballots and fake fraudulent
ballots and illegal ballots as they
could count if they still couldn't come
up with that last 10,000 so Bill Nelson
finally conceded here's a Nelson's
concession address well things worked
out a little differently than grace and
I'd hoped but let me say I by no measure
feel defeated and that's because I've
had the privilege of serving the people
of Florida in our country for most of my
life and I don't think anybody could
have been as blessed it's been a
rewarding journey as well as a very
humbling experience
I was not victorious in this race but I
still wish to strongly reaffirm the
cause for which we fought a public
office is a public trust is that what
happens when you serve in the Senate for
three terms do you inevitably become
that guy that guy who does he have any
human left in him he's just a good old
politician and I'm gonna force that
smile even though I want to murder about
half of the constituents in my state but
I will like to congratulations morphs
into he's just a purely plastic
politician it's amazing he got as far as
he did especially you know Rick Scott is
a pretty good it was a pretty good
governor is pretty good candidate but
he's at Bill Nelson is finally out I'm
very glad that takes care of Florida
then you move
up to Georgia George is the ridiculous
one I actually understand why the
Democrats held out in Florida because
one it's extraordinarily corrupt and two
these were close votes even before all
these fraudulent ridiculous days later
recounts and new ballots coming in it
was a very close vote Florida is known
for close votes and then when you add
these corrupt officials like Brenda
Snipes in there they probably thought
maybe we can squeak it by maybe we can
steal this election that's fine people
have been stealing elections in America
for as long as the country has existed
especially Democrats because they're
very good at it
so I kind of understand it they're the
one that is puzzling is Stacey Abrams
Stacey Abrams was running against Brian
Kemp to be the governor of Georgia the
Republican Brian Kemp won he didn't win
by 10,000 votes he didn't win by 30,000
votes he won by 55,000 votes he won by
one point four percent that is not that
close you know you see that automatic
recounts are triggered at 0.25 percent
maybe 0.5 percent this is 1.4 percent
it's three times the number that
triggers an automatic recount in Florida
and so he wins by a fair bit this is
Stacey Abrams total sore loser awful
candidate boasted about how illegal
aliens are part of her motor coalition
not a good idea for future candidate so
we were taking notes right now don't do
that that's not that doesn't play well
with voters so she constantly was trying
to drag this thing out she wouldn't
concede she's still barely conceding
here is stacey abrams talking to Jake
Tapper after it's all but been admitted
around the country that the Republican
Brian can't beat her do you think that
Brian camp is not the legitimate
governor-elect of Georgia the law as it
stands says that he received an adequate
number of votes to become the governor
of Georgia and I acknowledge the law as
it stands I am a lawyer by training and
I am someone who's taken a
constitutional oath to uphold the law
but we know some time the law does not
do what it should and that something
being legal does not make it right this
is someone who has compromised our
systems he's compromised our democratic
systems and that is not appropriate
and therefore my mission is going to be
to make certain no one else has to face
this conversation the law as it stands
listen to what she's saying read between
the lines here she's saying well yes
according to the law the person who wins
the most votes becomes the governor
yeah that's according to the law but
sometimes the law gets it wrong meaning
the people got it wrong meaning that the
person who gets the most votes should
not become the governor that there
should be some new election a runoff
election another recount we're gonna
discover new ballots some where she is
saying she says look I'm a lawyer I
guess she's a lawyer she's pretty
certainly pretty slippery she's got some
of the traits of lawyers stereotypically
but what she is arguing against is the
ability of Georgians to choose their
governor says yeah I guess technically
according to the law he won the election
but I don't think he should have won the
election and therefore she's suggesting
that he stole it I mean that's the quote
that that an Abraham's loss in Georgia
is that this is the suggestion among
Democrats that he stole the election it
was illegitimate it was unfair it wasn't
he won the election he didn't win it by
a little couple of thousand votes or ten
thousand words he wanted by a good
margin but they won't even concede that
because to them to progressives anytime
a conservative wins that is illegitimate
why is it illegitimate because there's
progress there's progress to be made
that's why we're progressives isn't it
there's a utopia at the end we're going
to get to it and if you stand in the way
of progress if you stand up word history
yelling stop then you must be either
stupid or evil you must be so stupid you
can't see the progress in front of you
or you've got to be evil you want to
stop people from living in this paradise
that the Democrats are gonna give you if
you just give them a little bit more
money in a little bit more power that's
what she means that's what all of these
Democrats mean when they say it's
illegitimate the law failed democracy
failed they stole it what they're really
saying is anytime a conservative wins
that is illegitimate because it's
against progress this isn't just true in
the United States this is true in
Britain as well we'll get to that in a
second but first I notice it's time to
make a little bit more money and I can
notice that because I'm wearing my sweet
movement watch that I get compliments on
the time you know about movement we've
been talking about movement for a very
long time these guys started the company
college dropouts they've now sold almost
2 million watches worldwide by bringing
quality design at fair prices with the
holiday season coming giving gifts is
easy with movements a versatile line of
watches glasses and accessories so their
branch deaths not just watches anymore
they've got bracelets they've got
glasses all really high quality I've got
a bunch of their product I love it I've
given it away to friends too you know I
wear my movement watch I get compliments
on it this one is the Atlas from the
revolver collection they have a new
collection though which movement if
you're listening I really want this one
or at least a little a little discount
deal on it they have the new automatic
watch so they've got quartz watches
which look great incredible value and
then they've got a little bit more
expensive and automatic watch so it's
automatic movement it's it's charged by
the movement of your wrist incredible
mechanical design it's really really
excellent that also in an affordable
price these watches if you bought them
in a department store would be hundreds
of dollars maybe upwards of a thousand
dollars this now you can get them for
ninety five bucks that's where they
start and they you know they increase in
price I think the automatic watch is
just about three hundred an incredible
deal for that kind of technology and
that kind of design excellent excellent
product and it's a it's a ground up
entrepreneur story it was a crowdfunded
start up yet they've now sold a ton of
watches in over 160 countries
unbelievable and end with the Black
Friday coming up and Cyber Monday coming
up and get it now cuz they're running
great deals you can get 25% off today
during movements Black Friday Cyber
Monday sale I know what you're thinking
it's not Black Friday it's not Cyber
Monday the sale is on right now do it do
not miss this opportunity free shipping
and free returns MVM t.com slash cough
fa CoV f e fe this is the perfect gift
for Christmas for Hanukkah for whatever
holiday that you're gonna give a give
for it's great MVM t.com slash cough fa
co v fe fe they launched new styles on
the site all the time check it out and
join the movement so the left
undermining democracy and ironically
undermining liberalism is not just
happening in the United States it's
happening in Britain is
it's happening with the brexit vote do
you remember brexit do you remember a
brexit it was the British exit from the
European Union they voted on this they
voted on this in June of 2016 that also
was not a close vote
we were told oh the forces of staying in
the European Union they're gonna win it
by a landslide hey guys who want to
leave the EU don't even go vote don't
even you know the polls look at the
polls there's no way you could possibly
win does that sound familiar I think
we've heard that in the United States
before so they go and they do the vote
and the leave segment it was leave or
remain those who want to leave the EU
those who want to remain in the EU leave
won by 52% rather with 52% of the vote
52 to 48 to leave the EU that was in
June of 2016 and yet for some reason
right now Britain is still in the
European Union why is that the reason is
it is very difficult to pull yourself
out of these supranational transnational
extra national organisations this is why
the United States for centuries at this
point since the very founding since the
Washington administration has been wary
of entangling ourselves in super
national empires because once you're in
them once you give up that national
sovereignty once you give up your
Liberty it is very difficult if not
impossible to get it back so Theresa May
the Prime Minister of the United Kingdom
has promised she said we are going to
negotiate the brexit we're gonna fulfill
the promise of brexit what did she
promise she said Britain would leave the
single market and the regulations of the
European Union what is going to happen
under her new brexit negotiation deal
the reality is that the Great Britain is
going to be subject to exactly the same
common rulebook they're changing the
name of it but it's exactly the same
rules and regulations and single market
as they're currently in with the EU
another promise was that Britain would
leave the customs union that they would
be free to sign free trade deals with
other countries they can make a free
trade deal with the United States they
can make a free trade deal with anybody
bilateral trade deals the reality now
with this awful brexit deal
this fake brexit deal from teresa may is
that Britain will stay in the customs
union
there will be no ability to negotiate
free trade deals with other countries
what about the European Court of Justice
brexit promised teresa may promised when
she negotiated the deal that britain
would be able to leave the European
Court of Justice this extra national
transnational judicial body that
overtakes national sovereignty in this
fake Rexha deal the United Kingdom
remains in the European Court of Justice
on regulations on trade and the UK
courts have to follow it it's a big
fake-out it is not Rex it is as though
the people voted to leave the European
Union and then a bunch of people on both
sides of the aisle labour Tory whatever
they said okay we're gonna follow the
will of the people and then neither side
is doing it how did this happen if the
majority of your citizens vote for
something on a referendum promised that
it would take effect why on earth would
the party that promised it pull out and
say no we're not actually going to do it
too recently no we're not actually going
to do it the first one is bureaucratic
pressure bureaucrats can outlast you
they are your rulers they've got time on
their side you don't have time on your
side if another brexit vote were given
today would it would it pass would would
the British people vote to leave the
European Union I'm not sure a lot of
left wingers George Soros in particular
are trying to have another referendum to
undo it they're just this is what they
do they do it in Florida they just keep
voting and voting and voting until they
get the answer that they want but also
one the tide of public opinion is going
to change but those bureaucrats from
Brussels to the United Kingdom those
those guys are not going to change a few
of the elected xagliv but the the actual
government forces the actual state is
not really going to change now the
Tories the Conservatives in the United
Kingdom
they're ostensibly the ones who are
supposed to be negotiating there's a
brexit deal they're supposed to be the
ones on the side of leaving but I think
a lot of them secretly wanted to remain
in the European Union they say oh those
people those country bumpkins they just
voted emotionally they're probably
clinging to their guns and religion oh I
don't know think they have that many
guns in Britain but those country
bumpkins shouldn't have done it they're
voting against their interest we know
better so we're going to mollify them
we're gonna pacify them and for
tended that we're pulling out of the EU
but really we're going to in effect have
exactly the same deal that we have now
and that's why you have now a number of
members of Teresa mayor's cabinet
resigning because the ones who actually
wanted the brexit are saying this is
nonsense you're trying to pull the wool
over our eyes no way
conservatives in the u.s. do this to
they do it all the time this is that
beltway thing that swamp thing that
Washingtonian establishment thing is
they go out in the campaign horde on
conservative issues and then what do
they do when they get to office nothing
they never intended to do it I've been
in a lot of campaigns I've met a lot of
elected officials and when you talk to a
lot of them the establishment type the
specifically the coastal type the ones
who have been in DC for a long time they
feel that they have much more in common
with elites in journalism and politics
on the other side of the aisle than they
do with their own base and with their
own constituents and probably they do
have more in common probably their their
living situation is much more similar to
elites on both side of the aisle
probably the music they listen to the
cocktail parties that they go to the
entertainment that they digest the books
that they read are actually probably
more similar among those self-appointed
benevolent better elites than they are
among their own base so they play to
their base they touch down on cultural
issues on immigration on issues that
really matter to the base which is
sophisticated by the way these aren't
just country bumpkins i I've talked to I
mean I've traveled all around the
country doing these speeches and I'll
talk to people in shops and ubers on
campuses and this in the so-called
country bumpkins and the flyover country
can articulate to me how policies affect
them and affect their communities much
better than anybody can in New York r-la
when I talk to people in New York or LA
they don't know who their congressman is
why not because they're in the center of
the world they don't think in such
provincial ways they only think of grand
matters like the European Union or the
United Nations or national politics but
people in the so-called flyover country
they do know who their congressman is
they know who their state senator is
they know who their Assemblyman is
they're much more in tune with the
individual
needs and demands of their communities
that's how that's why they know the
specifics of how national and state
policies affect them much better than
people on the coasts the other reason I
think that that Britain is trying to get
away with this that European elites are
trying to get away with this and why
Americans get away with this is because
conservatives by the left-wing cultural
line especially the elite conservatives
they by the line they hear that the left
and the culture they'll tell you that's
impossible
oh it's impossible to build a wall on
our southern border oh it's impossible
to renegotiate trade bills oh it's
impossible to enforce our immigration
laws it's just not fun look I know we
need to tell our dumb constituents that
it's that we're going to build a wall
but we can't really build a wall look we
I know we need to tell our constituents
who don't know as well as us because
they didn't go to Eton and Oxford and
Harvard there we need to tell them that
we're going to have the brexit but we
can't really do it it's not possible why
is it not possible if the Trump election
has taught us anything it's that we
should greatly expand our imagination
and the bounds of what we think is
possible
politically we've gotten a lot of things
done just one example they use this on
the train station or the train station
read the the embassy in Jerusalem the
United States Embassy in Israel is now
in Jerusalem you used to be in Tel Aviv
a lot of politicians have promised to
move it to Jerusalem and none of them
ever intended on doing it Donald Trump
actually did it expand your imagination
before we get into what's going to
happen in Great Britain in Europe let's
make a little money and let's talk about
something very important to our Liberty
talk about expanding your imagination
brownells a big proponent and supporter
of the Second Amendment it has been
around for 80 years you can buy guns
ammo accessories online it's convenient
it's totally legal it is the greatest
online marketplace to buy firearms and
firearm accessories it is wonderful a
lot of new people these days are taking
an interest in firearms well you know
sometimes I think people think that gun
owners and gun enthusiasts are like 175
year old old men with moustaches that's
not true a lot
new demographics after that shooting a
pulse nightclub at the gay nightclub I
know a lot of gay people joined the NRA
started joining other gun clubs going to
the range buying firearms everybody
should do it women certainly should
there's one way for women to protect
themselves physically against men and it
is to have weapons to have firearms that
evens the playing field this is very
important it's important to protect our
rights now more than ever you have
congressman and elected officials who
are saying they're going to take away
your guns they're saying it openly
they're saying the government will come
for you and use the force of the state
protect yourself Bren Ansel is the
world's leading supplier of firearms
ammunition firearm accessories reloading
components and more they offer an
industry exclusive guaranteed forever
warranty on all parts and accessories
they have one hundred twenty thousand
items from new guns and ammo to nearly
any gun part imaginable it's a great
organization they've also been
supporting law enforcement and charities
and military charities for 80 years
throughout the month of November Brian
Ellis is working to help veterans in a
big way Branagh is hashtag Operation
100,000 event is soliciting donations
from customers they'll match every donor
dollar up to $100,000 donations will be
divided between three well-respected
military charities you've probably heard
of them Special Operations Wounded
Warriors mission 22 folds of Honor you
can donate by adding money to your
purchase from brownells.com by visiting
brownells.com slash Operation 100k or
donating directly brownells.com visit it
today pick up some gun gear help out
with a great cause defend your rights
other people aren't going to defend them
for you you got to make sure that you
can back all that up it's great I love
that website so what is next for Britain
what is actually gonna happen out there
possibly Theresa May is out the Prime
Minister of Britain may be out over this
she's already had five resignations from
her cabinet she might have two more
resignations possibly Boris Johnson
might be at Boris Johnson he's the
politician in the UK who just looks like
Donald Trump he's probably the slightly
more classically educated Donald Trump
but he's got the same hair he's got the
same effect he's a terrific politician
and he might be in there there's a lot
of talk that he might become the next
prime minister this would be a welcome
change because Britain is on the cusp of
so
of Jeremy Corbyn hard left style
socialism they are so close to it right
now
yeah you could Britain has been through
a lot in its history it faces a perilous
moment and they need to make sure that
this brexit goes through they need to
make sure that it's a real bricks and
not a fake rec set but who knows I mean
this is a this is a real turning point
you always hear in the u.s. this is the
most important election of our lifetimes
is the most important election blah blah
blah 99% of the time it's not this is a
very important moment for the history of
Britain they're either gonna Carine
toward insane leftism give up their
national power or they're gonna take a
stand for Britain I hope they do the
latter as someone of partially British
descent I hope that they stand for for
their country and for their liberties
and for the people who have voted and
who they're supposed to be representing
we have a lot more to get to we're going
to talk about why young people are not
having sex we're gonna talk about the
Bolsheviks at Google and we're going to
talk about Johnny Bobbitt not John Wayne
Bobbitt not the one who had that
unfortunate incident with John Jr and
his wife and a knife but a Johnny
Bobbitt who is the homeless guy who
scammed all of America but first go to
daily wire.com if you're ready there
thank you you help keep the lights on
you keep Co FFA in my cup if not do you
hear that do you hear the bells chiming
the birds singing that's because it's
almost time for our next episode of the
conversation featuring me little old
Michael Knowles on Tuesday November 20th
at 5:30 Eastern 2:30 Pacific I'll be
taking all of your questions easing your
anxiety by answering you live on air
every query that has burned in your
hearts will be resolved best of all it's
an extra hour-long dose of you guessed
it the guy with two thumbs and a bunch
of cough FA this one I think it's all
you could really ask for really Plus
Elisha crafts will be there too that'll
be lovely this month's episode will
stream live on Daily wires YouTube and
Facebook pages it's free for everyone to
watch but only subscribers can ask the
questions to ask questions as a
subscriber log in to our website daily
wire.com go to the conversation page
watch the stream start typing into the
chat box you're there I'll answer your
questions I will I will so vastly
improve your life once again subscribe
to get your questions answered by me
Michael Knowles
today November 20th 5:30 Eastern 2:30
Pacific and joined the conversation I'm
trying to speak in my ben shapiro esque
speed voice because we have so much more
to get to you'll also get the daily wire
tumbler if you subscribe
the leftist tears tumblr the vessel the
only one that can capture both Andrew
Gilliam and Bill Nelson and Stacey
Abrams as tears that's a lot you should
subscribe twice so you can get to you
don't want to have some spill and
radioactivity going on read your hats go
to daily wire.com we'll be right back
with a lot more
who cares about the elections who cares
about brexit the real problem the Great
Plague facing this country young people
are not having sex anymore
this is true they're not having sex
there's an article right now in the
Atlantic they refer to the sex recession
that's going on in the United States it
doesn't make any sense
you would figure right now that sex
would be more prevalent than you could
possibly imagine there the dating apps
there is a study out that shows 50% of
people sext they send pictures of
themselves on text and leave electronic
paper trails of their degeneracy like a
bunch of idiots what are you thinking
what are you people thinking but I mean
there were Teen Vogue Teen Vogue ran an
entire feature on how to have sexual
relations in places that you're not
supposed to have sexual relations they
ran in it's a Teen Vogue not regular
vogue you know regular vogue adults get
a little creative sometimes a little
curious Teen Vogue
ran that that feature and yet
nevertheless all of this social mores
relaxed people there are 56 genders now
according to Facebook so logistically
probably it should be pretty easy to
find a partner to get around and bump
uglies and yet nevertheless new studies
show that teens and young adults are
having less sex than ever between 1991
and 2017 the percentage of high school
students who have had sex dropped from
54% to 40% now in some ways I suppose in
a if you look at it from a moral
perspective or the perspective of a out
of wedlock birth or abortion then that's
all very good but from a cultural
perspective measuring libido and
relations between the sexes this is a
little curious why is it that when we've
got this total sex soaked culture you
can't turn on a TV show you can't look
at a billboard without seeing near
nudity nobody's having sex anymore I
think that's part of the reason people
in their early 20s right now are two and
a half times as likely to be abstinent
as people in Generation X fit for T is
50 s why is it in
part it's there's a decline in
couplehood so they've studied those
people who would say that their couples
has declined dramatically now people are
hooking up a little bit there is a
hookup culture but actual
boyfriend/girlfriend if you have the flu
I'll get you chicken soup kind of
couples don't really exist and does
anybody who's ever been single or in a
couple will tell you when you're in a
couple you're going to have sex much
more frequently I don't care what kind
of lothario Don Giovanni you think that
you are it just is a numbers game it's
just not going to happen as much if you
don't have a regular old sweetheart
another reason for this is that
one-third of parents or rather one-third
of adults under the age of 35 are living
with their parents this is a very sad
state of affairs i I've got friends who
are like this I've actually got a number
of friends who are like this so if
they're watching the show my apologies
don't want to and make you feel bad but
come on you got I mean it's very
difficult to maintain an active sex life
if you're living with your parents at
the age of 35 and it's happening around
the world it's not just happening in the
United States we you've always heard
about Japan Japan was always the example
of this because they've got broadly
speaking I don't wanna make any cultural
stereotypes here but they've got some
weird sexual preferences over there
you know you see sometimes images of
like squids and octopuses and I don't
remember Kurt I can Walt got wrapped up
in in octopus tentacle porn I know I'm
not trying to relive these images I'm
just telling you the Japanese have
always had a bizarre relationship to sex
and now according to a new study
actually a 2005 study so it's not even I
think the problem is actually gotten
worse since then one third of Japanese
singles between the ages of 18 and 34
were virgins guys what's going on
the Japanese analysts and pundits have
blamed this on a term that I think we've
got to bring into the United States
grass-eaters
I don't remember the Japanese word for
it but they're talking about grass
eaters herbivores is another one they're
talking about soy boys that's that's the
term they're you know in the US and
especially these days you hear terms
like beta or coq or soy boy or or vegan
or whatever you know they're all these
terms that the Japanese have exactly the
same terms but it's it's not just
in Britain there was a study or in Japan
rather there was a study a while ago in
Japan that more young Japanese men would
rather have a night with a computer and
pornography than have sex with a woman
it was the majority of Japanese men
that's not good it's also true in
Britain this is also true in Australia
it's also true in Finland and the
Netherlands that people are having less
sex why I think there are three culprits
that we can point to in the immediate
aspect which is the hookup culture and
porn and tinder because they're all
fantasies all of them are the hookup
culture you know the hookup culture
dominates especially college campuses
these days but even you know young urban
professionals people in cities there's a
hook-up culture so you're not
necessarily dating someone or going
steady with someone or it's your
boyfriend or girlfriend you're hooking
up a number of people who were surveyed
by this Atlantic article said they hook
up because they don't have social skills
so they get blackout drunk they go they
see a person who's reasonably attractive
and they go and hook up with them and
then maybe they call them probably they
don't call them the next day this is a
fantasy as as it pertains to having less
sex because when you think back on the
hookup culture all you remember are the
victories all you remember the nights
that you went home with somebody
well you don't remember are the times
that you struck out the times that
you're too sloppy drunk the times that
you went home and you wish somebody
would bring you soup because you've got
the flu you don't remember that you only
remember all the times that you went
home with a cute chick from a bar or a
party or whatever and that's a fantasy
the same thing with porn porn as a
fantasy porn is ubiquitous it is used by
virtually every guy from very young ages
now I mean it comes in via fast internet
connections you can see anything in the
world the old joke is that if you can
imagine it there's a porn for it I don't
think that's even a joke anymore I think
Kurt I can wall prove to us that that's
true with the weird tentacles from Japan
so a porn is this other fantasy because
when you when you get excited about
pornography it's because you're gonna
see naked chicks and weird
octopuses or whatever your thing is but
the reality of pornography is that
you're
sitting alone in a room with a computer
pleasuring yourself and and I mean that
both is a physical act and as a
spiritual and psychological life you're
just pleasuring yourself it's ubiquitous
I'm not judging the statistical 100
percent of my audience male audience
that looks at four and I'm just saying
it is a fantasy that's why it's such a
temptation that's why it's something
that should be resistant and the other
fantasy is tinder tinder and all of the
dating apps where you swipe right swipe
left is a fantasy because while I know
people who have gotten married off of
tinder I've been to weddings where
people get married off of tinder the
majority of time spent on tinder is not
time meeting people hooking up finding a
wife the majority of time on tinder is
just wasted time swipe swipe a couple
messages swipe swipe swipe swipe so you
think you've got access to all of the
women of the world at your fingertips
but in reality it's just an illusion
it's a mirage swipe swipe swipe and a
lot of people have written into the show
and they said they don't even get people
to write back it's just taking up all of
their time so that's a culprit another
culprit is feminism I know it's easy to
blame feminism for everything so I will
do that but feminism is a major problem
here because feminism is trying to take
all of the love and the care and the
complementarity of the sexes out of
relationships the great example of this
is as we approach Christmas season is
baby it's cold outside you know for the
last few years feminists have waged war
on baby it's cold outside because they
say it's a it's a rapey song it promotes
a rape just insane the lyrics of baby
it's cold outside
or I really can't stay baby it's cold
outside I've got to go away baby it's
cold outside this evening has been so
very nice I'll hold your hands they're
just like ice and what the feminists
hear is a woman who's saying I want to
leave and a man who's saying you should
stay and that makes him a rapist he's a
rapist how he's not listening to her no
what they misunderstand his seduction
coyness modesty the virtue of modesty
which has been erased from feminist
culture the woman who's saying I really
shouldn't stay is not saying I'm in an
alleyway help me help me I want to get
out of here she's with this guy that she
likes she's before the fire they're
having a couple drinks she wants to stay
what the reason she
is resisting is because of the virtue of
modesty she doesn't want to lose her
reputation she doesn't want to seem too
easy she doesn't want to seem like she's
giving in and then he is trying to
seduce her and persuade her to stick
around the other line they mentioned
about baby it's cold outside is she's
they say she asks say what's in this
drink and the guy says no cabs to be had
out there this is a joke from the 30s
and 40s
when again in response to the virtue of
modesty you want to do something that
you're not really supposed to do then
you could blame it on having too much to
drink or there's a roofie in your drink
or whatever you're trying to give away
responsibility for the act that you want
to do but even broadly even taking these
exaggerations out the song is about a
man who wants a woman and a woman who
clearly wants the man to but is trying
to resist and that is the game because
traditionally romantic relations between
the sexes involve male assertiveness and
then women ultimately deciding if
they're gonna stay or not if they're
gonna give in to the guy or not women
have totally eradicated this now
everything has to be consensual there's
no difference between men and women it's
it's all about consensual contracts of
course baby it's cold outside is about
consent too
it's about a man trying to persuade the
woman to give it give away the virtue of
modesty for a night and have a little
indiscretion and they can enjoy each
other that is consent - but it's not
clinical consent it's not signing a
piece of paper and saying we're gonna do
this and we're gonna do this and then
we're gonna do this
for feminists they've wiped all of this
out and it's made relations between the
sexes pretty hard is a man allowed to
seduce a woman anymore is a woman
allowed to pay lip service to the virtue
of modesty anymore what what our dates
looking like what do what does the
relationship between the sexes look like
when feminists deny that there's any
difference at all I think that's a big
part of it but either way I feel sorry
for you young people that yeah you're
also terribly
I think involuntarily abstinent at the
moment and you're just giving into porn
and selfishness that's not great it's
very fun women are great it's great to
spend time with women it's great to be
respectful and it's great to be a man
and it's great to be a woman and the
more our culture is confused about what
all those things are the less you're
going to see men and women interacting
in in any sort of capacity johnny
Bobbitt I got to talk about this this is
something I'm very grateful for as we
approach Thanksgiving Johnny Bobbitt is
this homeless guy he's a bum you might
remember him because about a year ago
almost exactly a year ago November 2017
this woman Cape McClure 28 years old and
her boyfriend Marc D'Amico who is a bit
older they had this story where they
said Kate ran out of gas on i-95 and it
was in November and she was so cold and
she couldn't figure out what to do in
Johnny Bobbitt Jr a a wonderful homeless
man with a heart of gold took the last
20 dollars out of his pocket and gave it
to her so that she could fill up her gas
tank this is so heartwarming the medium
loved this story here's here's Good
Morning America talking about it just
remind yourself of this heartwarming
story so you're not wearing the glasses
because you're Hollywood now I'm fixing
a Mariah
but it's Johnny Bobbitt Jr's face and
story that's gone viral with thousands
giving to the good samaritan after an
honorable deed two months ago I was
driving down 95 and ran out of gas so I
pulled over onto the side of the road he
walked up and he said get back in the
car
lock the doors you know I'll be back
Kate McClure says she could tell the man
walking up to her off the highway was
homeless the other guy has to help her
get back on her way
wasn't it expecting anything in return I
mean my boyfriend Marco in fact the next
day he gave him $100 I was ecstatic that
gesture of helping stranded motorists is
something Johnny has done countless
times how often would you go to see
Johnny a few times a week unknowingly he
was about to get hit with Karma what if
we started a GoFundMe for this guy
we set it up in the car on the way home
they started GoFundMe they raised
$400,000 isn't that's for Johnny who
helped her out gave her his last 20
bucks he's always helping motorists
because Johnny's such a good guy and
Nate this couple they just decided and
goodness of their heart to help men and
that's so wonderful the trouble with the
story is it's completely fake is
completely fake news whenever is
somebody tells you that the news media
don't run fake news point them to this
story because it wasn't just ABC
everybody ate this story up ran with it
it's a total hoax Johnny never gave her
20 bucks to fill up her gas tank she
didn't run out of gas on i-95 they they
didn't end up giving Johnny a lot of
this money this was all a scam
perpetrated by Cape McClure and her
boyfriend Marc D'Amico and they found
this homeless guy Johnny that is true
they found they found this dude and they
used him and they offered to give him a
portion of the money and they played on
people's heartstrings and they raised
$400,000 it all started to unravel when
Johnny Bobbitt sued the couple because
they weren't giving him enough of the
money and they were spending money on
vacations they were spending money on
BMWs and Mercedes I mean really nice
cars and so eventually he sued and then
this thing started to unravel what does
this tell us what are the lessons as we
approached think Thanksgiving first of
all the press doesn't do his job the
press doesn't investigate these things
that the media should have investigated
this before they ran this story from
coast to coast and they didn't do it
because they're weak journalists and
they're not living up to their
profession okay also the American people
aren't doing their job do-gooders aren't
doing their job they should look into
this every time somebody puts their hand
out and says give me some money it's
good to give charity I love giving
charity I think everybody should give
charity but you got to make sure that
you're not empowering scam artists and
this also teaches us a Courtin lesson
about virtues because I got this
question when I was on the road this was
from a girl who said I'm a Christian and
I really want to know how to approach
immigration and illegal immigration
because my compassion tells me we should
take in everybody anybody who wants to
come in anybody's here illegally we
should just take them in well how am I
wrong shouldn't a Christian do that you
say yes a Christian should be merciful
and compassionate and charitable but a
Christian should also be prudent a
Christian should also not create
perverse incentives that hurt people who
cross the border illegally or that hurt
the country and make it
less capable of giving charity in the
future there are many virtues there are
seven virtues faith hope and charity
another four virtues fortitude justice
prudence and temperance and prudence is
the important one here you shouldn't be
imprudent you should you should use your
knowledge you should use the rational
faculties and your wisdom to seek out
what the truth of a situation is because
I think it's just you're Chesterton
talked about this how when you just take
one virtue and you promote that virtue
to the exclusion of all of the other
virtues you can actually make it more
closely resemble a vice than a virtue if
you have only mercy without any justice
that it that's not a virtue that's not a
great virtue if you have only justice
without any mercy how can you have true
justice in a world of fallen men and
when you just give your money away I
know we're too rich as a country we just
want to give it away we feel like we're
not good people
we don't go to church anymore we don't
go to we don't participate in
traditional charity we don't participate
in our communities so when it when we
see a gofundme in a heartstring story we
just want to donate money to it but
you've got to use your prudence as well
and you you can't choose one virtue and
exclude all of the others so while we're
giving Thanksgiving well we're so happy
for all the blessings that we have well
we want to extend those blessings to
other people you've got to use your head
you don't want to make a situation worse
you don't want to empower bad people and
bad actors you want to use the resources
that you have wisely this is a lesson
that we can take personally and
nationally we've got a lot more to get
to but we're out of time too bad we'll
get to it tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Mills this is the Michael nul
show I'll see you tomorrow
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018